so Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe is
of course a parody on the story Punisher
kills the Marvel Universe but unlike the
story of Punisher kills the Marvel
Universe with this Deadpool story we're
gonna find a combination of dark humor
and parody and total insanity there's
really no other way to describe this
story it is probably one of the most
well written Deadpool stories but of
course is is very interesting um what
I'm going to try to do over the course
of this video is try to keep a straight
face because this story gets pretty
ridiculous at times it gets pretty funny
but as we pick up with this story we
were joined with The Watcher and what
The Watcher tells us is again his role
and the Marvel Universe that within the
multiverse his role is to observe all
realities and to chronicle those
realities and that there are countless
things that could happen in countless
worlds that all these different
realities could spin out from the same
action or that they could have all I
guess grown on their own that there's
really no limit to the possibility to
take place here he tells us that
multiple civilizations have come into
existence in these realities and that
some of these civilizations could have
ended in spectacular fashion while other
civilizations could have been brought to
an end by the hands of one man and what
he does is he takes us to into an
alternate reality whereby it appears as
though someone most likely Deadpool has
killed the Fantastic Four
he's killed Reed Richards and Reed
Richards is of course stretched and
strung all over the place and Susan
storm is is trying to comfort him trying
to figure out what's going on here she's
of course trying to understand what it
is has taken place has led to this
circumstance whereby Reed Richards is
presumably dying Reed Richards tells
Susan storm not to worry about him that
is too late to worry about him that she
has to get herself to safety that she
has to warn everybody else of what's
going on he also goes as far as to say
that whoever's done this has stolen
something but of course Susan storm is
unable to get what it was that was
stolen she was unable to get really
Richards to say what it was from here we
see Susan storm Lee
and trying to come to grips with this a
little distraught at the fact that Ben
Grimm has been killed and of course she
asked Reed Richards about the children
about valaria and Franklin Reed Richards
says that he sent them to the negative
zone a place that whoever it was it has
done this could not get to them but the
problem is that the portal to the
negative zone has been destroyed which
is of course Marvel removing the element
of Franklin Richards in this reality
being able to correct it by a simple
will and so what we see is that is that
Franklin I'm sorry that Reed Richards
succumbs to his injuries that he ends up
dying from here there's some kind of an
explosion that takes place I mean the
drag Susan storms attention away from
Reed Richards so you of course makes
yourself invisible and goes to
investigate and when she does she ends
up in the hangar and in the hangar of
course where the Fantastic Four jet is
stationed the entire room is on fire and
the jet appears to have exploded and
inside I guess outside of this jet is
Johnny Storm trying to crawl his way to
safety of course he's not being injured
by the flames but it seems as though
he's been cut by by a blade of some kind
at this point is revealed to us that
Deadpool is the one that has done this a
Deadpool has killed her had killed both
Reed Richards and and Ben Grimm and his
killing Johnny Storm
and he tells Johnny Storm that he put up
more of a fight than he expected that he
didn't expect Johnny Storm to be as
tough as he was and and he says he has
the third degree burns to prove it
he tells Johnny Storm that that you know
it was a it was a really nice nice jet
that had to be destroyed for the purpose
of trying to kill Johnny Storm
but Deadpool uses the analogy of saying
in order to make an omelet you have to
break a few eggs and so what we see is
that he kills kills Johnny storm and
when he slices his throat that blood has
sprayed all over a Susan storm which of
course results in deadpool being able to
see Susan storm in her an invisible
state from here Susan storm uses her
ability to create force fields to create
a force field inside the head of
Deadpool and this results and of course
Deadpool's head exploding and Susan
storm tells him that she doesn't know
why he's done this why he's attacked her
family but that he's never going to be
able to do it again but of course what
Susan storm fails to realize here is
that Deadpool's healing factor allows
his head to regrow and when he does when
his head
back he stabbed Susan storm through the
back with one of his swords from here
The Watcher gives us the back story of
what it was that had taken place of what
it was that had happened that had led to
this set of circumstances whereby
Deadpool is killing the Fantastic Four
and he transfers us or sends us to a
place called ravenscroft's Asylum and
inside of this Asylum it appears as
though an individual named dr. Benjamin
Brighton is the one running the show
he's the head doctor here and what we
learn is that Deadpool Deadpool is being
checked into this Asylum by this
reality's version of the x-men due to
the fact that he is totally insane and
it seems as though there's no one that
can help him of course the Deadpool
takes this as some kind of a joke and
that believes that maybe they're all
taking turns being tied to the gurney
and that is going to be storms storms
turn next of course dr. Brighton greets
Charles Xavier and tells Charles Xavier
that while his methods are unorthodox
that he'll be able to help Deadpool
he'll be able to cure Deadpool of what
it is it makes him insane
and restore him back to a state of
normalcy of course Deadpool says that he
doesn't do very well with institutions
that he has he has several failed
marriages indicating he doesn't do well
with the institution of marriage that he
has an overdrawn bank account so he
doesn't do well with the financial
institution and that he burned the
Smithsonian to the ground
of course again dr. Brighton takes this
to indicate Jisoo exactly how insane
Deadpool is and what we do is we
transition to the office of dr. Brighton
where Deadpool is being brought in and
Deadpool is of course being interviewed
he's being questioned by dr. Brighton
and dr. Brighton again ask Deadpool to
sit down to have a seat and it seems as
though maybe he's looking to interview
Deadpool or to simply just have a
psychological session with Deadpool and
of course the hair Deadpool thinks that
him and dr. Brighton are gonna be
besties nothing if they're gonna be best
friends and so of course Deadpool begins
to speak with dr. Brighton and Deadpool
what he says is that he's used so many
different forms of his backstory that he
wants to use something new and so what
he tells dr. Bryden is that he was born
a Coal Miner's Daughter and back and
that his mother never breastfed him
enough and that none of the womb the
mothers in the neighborhood would
give him the time of day again what dr.
Brighton tells Deadpool here is that his
inability to focus his inability to to
pay attention to what he's doing to stay
focus on what it is that he's doing is
what makes him an inefficient killer and
what he says is that what dr. Brighton
is unable to fix psycho man will be able
to do instead and of course psycho man
is a villain we were previously aware of
but what he says or what uh what Wayne
Wilson says is that he's a very
efficient killer but then we see that
one of his other voices or a couple of
his other voices come into play when
they tell him that he's in it that he's
an inattentive killer and that of course
he's not very good and that he's very
selfish in the sack when he's when he's
with other women from here
dr. Brighton activates some kind of a of
a control box and this control box seems
to electrocute Deadpool and seems to
shock Deadpool and maybe subdue him and
again what we see taking place is that
that dr. Brighton is using some kind of
mind manipulation that perhaps he's
trying to take over the mind of Deadpool
or trying to control the mind of
Deadpool which in turn will make him a I
guess a henchman and indeed this is what
dr. Brighton says dr. Brighton says that
when he abandoned his quest to a conquer
the Microverse that he knew that when he
came to this reality that he was going
to need an army of sorts and that as in
this reality most of the superheroes are
simply just taking supervillains and
throwing them into an institution rather
than trying to reform them or putting
them in a normal prison and so what dr.
Brighton has been doing is he has been
taking all these various supervillains
and he has been converting their minds
in order to make them I guess part of
him in order to make them someone that
he can control and what we learn is that
that of course psycho man again is the
ones pulling the show here now we don't
know exactly how in depth psycho man is
here we don't know what role psycho man
plays but all we know is a psycho man is
the one that is controlling this entire
situation
in addition apparently dr. Bryden
believes that this mind consoler control
session has been brought to an end but
then we see that a third voice of Wade
Wilson arise and it simply just says
hello Wade and so what dr. Brighton says
is that they're all done here that
they're completely finished but deadpool
says that he's not done
and that he's just getting started and
what he tells dr. brighten is that his
uh his orderly should learn how to tie
or how to secure a hug me jacket and of
course he begins attacking her begins
trying to strangle dr. Brighton from
here the back of dr. Brighton's head
opens up and is revealed to us that
psycho man is actually controlling dr.
Brighton and that dr. Brighton is simply
just a robot and psycho man tells
Deadpool to obey Him he tells Deadpool
to to do as he says but of course the
third voice of Deadpool comes into play
and Deadpool grabs psycho man out of the
head of dr. Brighton and Deadpool says
that he can't he can't simply obey
psycho man at this point that he still
needs psycho man that he has a release
form and that psycho man's stamp of
approval that psycho man stamp of
approval is needed and he began smashing
he began smashing psycho man onto the
paper on the desk from here from here we
pick we pick up with a third voice of
Deadpool when Deadpool doesn't know who
this third voice is and he asks who this
who this third voice is and the voice
simply just says a Deadpool knows who he
is a Deadpool has been waiting for this
third voice to arrive for quite some
time that Deadpool has killed one of
them and that now it's time for him to
kill the rest that now it's time for him
to finish the job of course Deadpool as
he makes his way out of the building
sees and is approached by a multitude of
these villains in this reality that are
being held captive and of course they
asked Deadpool to let them out but
Deadpool says no Deadpool says that he's
going to put them out of their misery
and that they don't want to be around
for what's coming and so what Deadpool
does is he begins to pour gasoline all
over the place and set the place on fire
from here Deadpool asks this third voice
what happened to the other voices where
the other voice is at and the third
voice says don't worry about them that
they don't need him or the Deadpool
doesn't need them anymore and that this
voice was really hungry and so what the
watcher does is tell us that in some
worlds and
some other realities that psycho man
would have been successful and being and
being able to acquire an army that that
psycho man would have been successful in
being able to take over the world but
that in this reality that he had
basically awakened the killer inside of
Deadpool the Deadpool of course has a
has the element of himself
that makes him sarcastic where he makes
his joke and he has a dark humor but
rather than being reasonable Deadpool is
an outright killer now he's simply not
regular mercenary he's just a normal
murderer but as as The Watcher is
talking to us he's electrocuted work or
attacked in some way and what The
Watcher says is he doesn't know what's
happening here he doesn't understand
what's taking place and what bad Poole
says is that the object that he had
stolen from the lab of Reed Richards was
the object used to attack the watcher it
was an object used to subdue the watcher
and of course he says that it must have
been a kick in the kickin it must have
been a kick in the balls to realize that
Reed Richards was working on something
that could subdue the watcher The
Watcher says that he did not interfere
that he doesn't know how it is that Wade
Wilson is able to see him but Deadpool
says that he doesn't see things the way
the world normally does what the third
voice also to also tells Deadpool is to
ask the watcher something and what what
Deadpool asked the watcher is who it was
that he was talking to you which is of
course Deadpool breaking the fourth wall
and speaking about the fact that the
watcher was addressing us and so what
the what Deadpool does is he cuts the
head off the watcher and from here we
bring this video to an end as in the
next video we'll pick up with part two
and we find out what happens when
Deadpool leaves the confines of this
situation and goes out into the world
presumably killing the rest of the
Marvel Universe with that being said
hopefully in the next video I'll be able
to keep keep a straight face and laugh
less and yeah
I will catch you guys later peace